dominique vous êtes allé voir
aimé jacquet cette semaine à
clairefontaine et cette rencontre a été
prolifique puisque vous n'avez
absolument pas parler de football
ce qui a permis de découvrir qui était
vraiment aimé jacquet oui parce que
souvent on dit des méchas kekst un homme
triste figé bloqués je crois franchement
que c'est une erreur d'interprétation
à chacun son caractère et aimer vie ses
passions avec force pour comprendre le
personnage nous sommes allés à la
recherche de ses racines aimé et fidèle
à ses racines vous allez le sentir alors
à toi de jouer mais
[Applaudissements]
je suis né dans un tout petit village
qui s'appelle sail-sous-couzan qui est
fin fond de la loire entre la loire la
route à l'auvergne et mon père était
boucher ou chez de campagne donc savez
insérant sais ce que c'est que se lever
à 3 heures du matin et puis partir en
foire et puis en plus ramené les bêtes à
pied faire la triperie à l'abattoir
c'est je connais tout ça par coeur et
mais c'est ce que c'est que le travail
et ce n'est pas son vieil instituteur
monsieur rivière qui nous dira le
contraire à 90 ans pourrait mais il a
accepté de revenir dans l'école publique
aujourd'hui désaffectée devenir
entraîneur j'ai eu peur il est tellement
gentil tellement doux jésus ils vont me
le dévore aimons mais eh ben non je vais
très apprécié il a beaucoup de caractère
qui se défend très bien j'en suis très
fier
j'ai eu de la chance j'ai connu en le
nom de paysans qui est fabuleux fabuleux
parce que il la porte toujours ouverte
le couvert toujours sur la table et puis
j'ai connu après le monde ouvrier
mais dans la période où tout le monde
travaille et où irait du travail ou le
l'ambiance est extraordinaire
j'étais entouré choyé mes camarades
comme j'avais quelques dons de
footballeurs maintenant touré parce que
saint-etienne c'est [ __ ] et à que le
foot et quand on est vers on est vers
avis faut pas l'oublier
donc ma machine du mal tourné tout seul
donc j'ai eu la chance d'avoir un bon
pote qui qui s'est un petit peu sacrifié
pour moi pour me permettre d'aller à
l'entraînement il faisait le poste le
matin il s'appelle roger berne
ce qu'oublie de dire aimer c'est
qu'après l'entraînement 2010 à 10 heures
le soir il devait reprendre sa place de
fraser derrière les machines et ce cinq
jours par semaine
je ne suis passé professionnel qu'à 24
ans mais je suis je fais partie de la
génération du football a envoyé
on n'est pas si malheureux que ça dans
le monde touche faut pas croire mais on
a des visages du moment qui sont ici
sont pas qu'ils sont très sévères et qui
sont très méchants mais ça c'est la vie
de l'autre mais après avant ils se sont
pas des choses on a l'a vu la vie en
groupe
si si vous saviez ce que c'est beau la
vie en groupe de l'avant match
l'après match même si t'as perdu il ya
une espèce de communication qui est
forte que personne ne connaît qui est
fabuleuse moi c'est tout ce que j'aime
moi tout le reste
ma foi est-ce que c'est pas trop
difficile de se prénommer aimé oui moi
albert batteux disait toujours que
j'avais un superbe prénom qui me collait
bien qui collait bien moi non je dirais
que je ne vais pas du tout ce prénom
j'en ai voulu à mes parents de m'avoir
donné ce prénom je suis tiré mais alors
m'appelle mais à les gamins aimé mais
c'est lui mais si c'est pas bien c'est
mais je chatte au mieux mon prénom quand
même il est génial c'est aimé jacquet
c'est le vrai mais jacques neige
on dirait qu'il a pris une autre
dimension là depuis la victoire en
roumanie ah oui c est à nous et puis dit
les choses telles qu'il les pense
maintenant il ne rentre plus à
l'intérieur on espère qu'il va emmener
cette équipe de france très loin au
moins jusqu'à l'euro opi dans sa voiture
pour de bonnes choses
[Musique]